[音楽]
[拍手]
影響と言うということなのね入って行っていただいてからふっ
意外ですけど
まあ質問から会いたいと思うんですけれども皆さん
どんな部屋してレーザー
なおない体をないですよ苅田町ですん
はちょっともう一つ違う角度が質問実際お前
今皆さんが分で今時は
どうぞ
した夕方後
それぐらいだった
経済ん
まじ番組ナチュラルパンみたいじゃないですかねっ
グラダウンが親がー
というあのバーチャル日番組に行って自分の圧が
あるいは自分のフル笹が振り上げがとっ
見えるっていうか
こんくらいじゃいますか
同じとだけ言いましたね
やっぱりみんなが部分は必ずすんだよ
いると思うんですけれどもあーそのマジ老獪なことで慢心がある人もいればあるじゃ
ない
風呂までなことに関心がある人もいます
色大さじ3
お菓子文化祭あるという事で一つだしないよう火薬程度良いリーダーというか下
苦労があった
していただいた頃かなと思います
一方で私はグローバルなことと何か
老獪なことも
受容性があった
まずじゃあどうかなかつどうぞお待ち水ということが表明してるんですけども私の居間
でくっていうか今日は
人々の日々の生活に
いただけに特定ず関われるようです
私の活動の原点は灰色お教室
になります
学生時代にや保育前の掌底大学店舗使って
シーン家の供述をやる
大学教授の方に来ていただきます
やっても出動した
だから連絡だったんでなていたからでめちゃめちゃなって
相手ならになっていった分
何もないっ
床も壁も名城ボンクレーずじっぱなしの税務もグレー
範囲のでそれで会える病院
本教室を準備しているミーティングもやっぱり様起点までやってたんですけれどもこの
時に
商店街の美容室のおっちゃんなオーダー目の煮込みうどんを作ってきてくれたんですね
これお金のない学生じゃ皆さんいいところでもって
日本いう丼です
それがのバスが高齢者ですか
だけの食べ物ってすごく右奥に残れて何ですか
特に私が性の保持はまだ
町の人と関わらないんだ
言動かあるいはきたはずの兄長とかに触れたことがなかったのでも転びと言ってしまい
ました
この商店街の託すでよかってよ
a その氷室の深くなぁと警棒を使っていたフェをしたりとか
いうこともしました
旅の系やひどい乗るまでに大学を卒業しません
という風にマークを示すすると思うさえで商店街皆さん
信頼を得ることができる
ですね冒頭のん
質問に戻れないんだけれども
どんな味が好きず
アジだ商店街仲成果の活動を通して得た私の気0正
私はお茶子じゃした街が好きだ
最後までです
商店街ってここジャブとしてた方が面白いよねー
調停がそれぞれ個性が際立っ
次は商店主さんの補正がこの商店それぞれに表れている
で御坂ですよ
街前段そうですよねだけじゃなくて
町全体でも恋愛のあれば家交番がある
オペラバー
顎を叩けば応援そういう8の方が俺は面白いんじゃないから
これ私が活動していた商店街よね
同棲ですけれどもこういうございました
じゃないかなと思っています
新宿の飲み屋剤とかね保護者補助してますけれどもそういうものっていうものならない
んじゃないじゃないか
いらっしゃいます
でもに原因も交えていられるっていう
ということはありえないですよ
そもそも人間で性格が十人十色じゃないですか
爺さんの状況を持ちがいません
英学も違いますけど状況的には例えば
ものすごくに歩きにこう明日ウェイという
あればまあ
定時で聞いたとき今でいう大規模不都合なんですよ
4てるみたいやん
時高まり正解も違えば状況を違う
みんな違うということなどに今までの受精まで街が一つの烙印
人間を押し込む用意していきたい
いいもし町が io でごちゃごちゃしていればそのどこかに
移動する可能性がある
ごちゃごちゃした街は妖精が要請がありますか
映画方やだ
ところでましょう形成する
重要な要素の1つに農業がよ僕は持っています
きちんと制農業93回とっても面白い
そういう話をしたいと思います
時東京都の面白いですね
大きな粗品根拠があるっていう方も設けるじゃない
皆さんのまちがい
けれども
英語に進む質問
日本のいい
日本国んね時給衣食行事
飯田のあるぞ
東京都の食料自給率
キャンパー線
嘘だとで考えたくなければ
構造を押されてないん
[音楽]
どうぞの仏教主義ザサン
一つ
4ナンパん
なーんかなんでそんなに大きい数字ではないですけれども
東京都3期生300万人が
家族の3%が東京で採れたものだけ
多分生きて
そう考えるぞ
問題ていただいている
実際のところ
東京には農家さんが約1万人います
シーズンているのか誰もこの東京の女さん
飲んだぜは基調的なことにいわゆる ja 農業協同組合による一角の出荷というのが
ありません
なのでそれぞれ農家さんが独自に反動を持っていて独自のさあバイオ
場合は自己流でやっているから東京農協
なので農産物一つ一つ
の本性が現れる
まず細くなったんですけれども私は今までご古い性質という会社を供給して発電になり
ます
何をやっているかと言うとと母さんのもさん
この国サジ10人
州民の東山とミューザという a charlie をやっています
写真どちらかですね
jr の中央線の15分でいいの本舗ずになりますそれが発表を一つ
本当にいろんな a
そういいなっ
43つか出てきます
先ほど細部東京では農家さんみんながー
盗賊の期間で一つの pc 収納台フォームを作るかそういうこと大学ですね
ほんといろいろな大会の一つというようなもの
やはりだけではないアジエンスを作っていきたいとか
普段を作っていない
あとは誓うでは
牛があります
今淫穴て part マリオなんか伝わっています
けどもニューヨーカー誌というとみなさんが
こういうふうに本当にいいです
高政裕
のいろいろ出てくるの男性が学ばなきゃいけ得るオーナーです
氏は大変なんでちょっと神くれると思っ商事
ないのではないんですけれども
やっぱり一平が
たくさん集まった方がこれは絶対お醤油わけですよ
まあまあのパーティー
がええじゃんとかそうじゃないですか
登場人物の構成や無敵技っててくれ
集まってもます
消費者にとってもいろんな方がなぜか決めてお金だけが少しずつ願っています
生産者本人同士でもパーティーなどを作ったほうがやりがい
面白い
農家さんだって人間なんですよして来たかな
中谷人間なんで停学中にそういう
air
脳がさによって作り対策も違えば
やりたい互いを知ろう
東京農業というのは農家さんが自分のオリジナリティを出しやすい
を強くしやすい
まじにょんで
すごっ
増税でいるということに大事な要素の一つに食べ物がある
食べ物は皆の関心事です
良い食べ物を見てないなーっていう方が多分こんなん
いらっしゃらないと思います
食べ物誰だけど話が広がるこういうことになりますよね
冒頭に申し上げがオーダー目の煮込みうどん
調整買いを持参品って言ってくれた
それもう見られずのゴミうどんを食べてるだけ
本当に若いが性もジョン例外
食べると私の会社の中運用できるようになる
こういう本デー
方があるものというものがあります
施術農協をもっと身近に感じてもらおうということで
くにたちのとなりますの機能の畑森の映像じゃ
t の人がワーッとが集まっていてばいばい
けども
8位の人といってもただ味に関わりがある人ではありま
私サーリーのをやってい
その子供になると思います
いうのをこうやってみんなで2位に見え
じゃがいも法廷ということをすることで人と人とだった
あるんだなということを
関したしてください
違って街にとって a
あげ花というものがあります
というものは一つ一つどーむする
最良の触媒だなぁ
なので私は東京にも畑とか田んぼとヶ岳本を作る場所を残したいと思ってい
最後にもう一つまちづくりという観点から
もう一つ下げお伝えしたいことがあります
まちづくりという gackt 動画中津東はより大きな次元
社会活動の社会課題背景ながっているということです
例えば
私は思う応援しよう yuta
をしているわけですけれども文字を残していくということで将来の街の大一旦火を防止
するという効果があります
まあ独身者は土地利用
土地の利用方法の境界です皆さんが待ち全部見てよ
エラーとちょうど下半身要したという
変顔でいるわけです
なので味をこのようにしていきたいなというふうに考えは長期的に
を言うの持ちようっと
車両用貯金称えていた
当然ながら畑も土地の養蜂法の一つ
畑を受けしまうと思う
どうかの息子さんや娘さんが農業を継がない
動いられバー
東京の車それが今入ったら
阿部してしまうということも
おっしゃったいん
たしマジ演説して考えてるの
だけをてしまってそれが建てのアパートやー
私の習得や葉っぱ
銃弾になることは本当にいいことなんなのかと考えると私は疑問です
今某業有家のチーズは15%もあると言う
そしてこれからどんどん e 4
日本の人口は減っていくわけですね
あそうするのはかなりなきゃなくいます
駅が遠いを立て流男子8パートは
そう言っている人が誰もいなくてあるいは住んでいたとしても
処理が一人で住んでいるような
ところばかりでそういう大須3-8ですがどんどん増え打ちパウリ菅井があるところ
らしい
そこで私たちが農業を応援して農地を残していくということで言えば
大登山家送り食べることができるというふうに
このように老獪な書くとマジ作りは社会課題の解決にも
室約
立っているわけです
ということで今日は皆さんに
街頭痛
町ローカルという視点を
訂正させていただきました
そして私自身がごちゃごちゃ者が人生てい
ということも温暖いたしました
おそらくここに合わせる形の多くの札に対することに関心があるということはないかも
知れ
でもどんな8にも皆さんが住んでいる街にもまちづくりに汗をかいている人あります
冒頭のファイル教室にマレーがー
平成がを誰かがおっしゃっていました
このような小さな活動から
日本は変わっていくのかもしれない
おっしゃっていただきます
私たちが取り組んで言う
マチ付き廊下での活動は社会があったら社会課題を解決している
いいはどういうとの幸せにつながっている
私は喪失である
皆さんもぜひ住んでいる街よそういう残念で一度ご覧いただけたらうれしい
[拍手]